tu vas entrer à l'académie verte car
j'ai conçu un projet pour projet de vie
la minute $ l'heure du jour le jour de
la semaine deux semaines du mois le mois
de l'année l'année de gawlik quoi rien
ne sera laissé au hasard dans celui-ci
oh tu deviendras une adulte formidable
merci maman
je voulais juste vous rendre votre
dessin il te plaît pas non à une clé
beaucoup il était une fois un petit
prince qui habitait une planète à peine
plus grande que lui
moi qui croyais jamais trouvé personne
qui veuille entendre mon histoire
s'il vous plaît dessine moi en tout
il faisait quoi cet enfant dans le
désert on n'a jamais évoqué l'existence
d'une vie sur aucune planète
thales stéroïdes l'astéroïde b612
le petit passe elle aimait beaucoup les
couchers de soleil
tu as terminé tes devoirs de la journée
pas tout à fait finie je me suis fait un
ami si tu étudies à fond et que tu te
conforme rigoureusement à ton projet tu
pourras passer du temps avec son nouvel
ami l'été prochain tiens regarde les
étoiles se sont levés
et on vient jouer avec moi je ne peux
pas jouer avec toi je ne suis pas
apprivoiser
mais si tu m'as brivoise nous aurons
besoin de l'autre tu seras pour moi
unique au monde
essentielle est invisible pour les yeux
lorsque le moment sera venu pour moi de
mon année je devrais partir tout seul
tu sait piloter un avion toi
accroche toi
crois que moi j'ai plus trop envie de
grandir grandir c'est pas tellement ce
un problème
le problème c'est dit
adultes formidable
à